françaises français mes chers
compatriotes de métropole d'outre-mer et
de l'étranger je tenais en cet automne
2021 à revenir vers vous pour répondre
aux interrogations
parfois aux inquiétudes qui sont les
vôtres sur notre situation sanitaire
économique sociale et géopolitique
depuis près de deux ans nous sommes
confrontés à une pandémie exceptionnel
nous avons tous ensemble tenu et je le
crois fait à chaque étape des choix
collectifs
indispensable pour protéger chacun
d'entre nous et pour nous protéger comme
nation nos décisions se sont toujours
fondée sur la connaissance scientifique
sur l'impératif de nous protéger sur la
volonté d'agir de manière proportionnée
et sur la conviction que la
responsabilité individuelle et
collective sont notre première force
c'est cela qui nous a conduits à décider
à deux reprises d'un confinement quand
il le fallait au printemps puis à
l'automne 2020 ensuite à tenir bon avec
un couvre-feu et des règles adaptées à
chaque territoire
au début de cette année 2021 alors que
beaucoup de nos voisins ferme et où
nous avons depuis le début de cette
année 2021 puis disposer de vaccins en
acheter puis en produire l'union
européenne a ainsi produit plus de 2
milliards de doses de vaccins durant
cette année soit plus qu'aucune autre
puissance du monde
s'agissant de la france depuis la
première vaccination en décembre 2020
nous avons injecté en dix mois plus de
100 millions de doses
51 millions d'entre vous sont
aujourd'hui complètement vaccinés ce qui
fait de nous l'un des pays du monde les
mieux protégés
grâce au pass sanitaire et à la
stratégie mise en oeuvre depuis le mois
de juillet dernier nous sommes parvenus
à maîtriser l'épidémie
en rappelant ses choix et nos résultats
j'ai en cet instant une pensée à la fois
respectueuse et ému
pour tous nos compatriotes qui ont
disparu et pour leur famille et je veux
à nouveau remercier nos soignants nos
volontaires nos associations toutes
celles et ceux qui ont contribué à tous
ses efforts pour autant nous n'en avons
pas terminé avec la pandémie
d'abord parce que des dizaines de
milliers de nos compatriotes sont
touchés par ce qu'on appelle le qu'ovide
long dont les symptômes qui sont la
perte de goût d'odorat l'épuisement
la dégradation de la santé mentale font
l'objet d'une prise en charge spécifique
ensuite parce que nous le savons il nous
faudra vivre avec le virus et ces
variants jusqu'à ce que la population
mondiale dans son ensemble soit immunisé
et c'est pour cela que d'ailleurs dès le
début de la pandémie la france s'est
engagée pour donner des doses aux pays
les plus pauvres et les pays en voie de
développement
nous sommes au rendez vous de cette
solidarité internationale et nous
continuerons de le faire
nous n'en avons pas terminé parce qu'à
court terme
l'organisation mondiale de la santé le
dit la cinquième vague a commencé en
europe au royaume uni en allemagne plus
de 30 mille nouveaux cas supplémentaires
sont enregistrées chaque jour et si
grâce à vos efforts la situation en
france est plus favorable
l'augmentation de 40% en une semaine de
notre taux d'incidence est la remontée
des hospitalisations sont des signaux
d'alert
de même que la situation dans certains
territoires d'outre-mer où la
vaccination demeure encore insuffisante
dans bien des cas et qui ont beaucoup
souffert ces derniers mois je veux ici
leur dira à nouveau la solidarité
nationale et leur dire que tout
continuera d'être faits comme depuis le
début de la crise
tout cela doit nous conduire à la plus
grande vigilance
et nous pousser à agir
parce que nous avons fait le nécessaire
pour nous protéger nous pouvons
continuer à maîtriser la situation
si chacun d'entre nous prend sa part
mon premier message est ainsi un appel
un appel à l'esprit de responsabilité
et six millions d'entre vous qui n'ont
encore reçu aucune dose de vaccin
vaccinez vous vacciner vous pour vous
protéger la vaccination est ouverte à
tous sauf aux enfants de moins de 12 ans
je rappelle qu'une personne vaccinée à
11 fois moins de chances de se retrouver
à l'hôpital en soins critiques
je rappelle aussi que des milliards
d'individus sur la planète ont déjà eu
le vaccin et que nous avons maintenant
déjà un certain recul
vaccinez vous pour pouvoir vivre
normalement
avec le vaccin il vous sera possible
d'obtenir un pass sanitaires et ainsi de
vous rendre librement dans les cafés les
restaurants les lieux de culture de
sport de loisir sans test pcr
être libre dans une nation comme la
france
implique d'être responsable et solidaire
je compte donc sur vous
face au regain de l'épidémie les plus
vulnérables sont nos aînés et ceux qui
souffrent d'obésité de maladies
cardiovasculaires de maladies
respiratoires ou de diabète sévère
toutes les études montrent en effet que
six mois après le vaccin
l'immunité diminue et donc que le risque
de développer une forme grave réaugmente
la solution à cette baisse d'immunité et
l'injection d'une dose de vaccins
supplémentaires ce qu'on appelle le
rappelle une campagne a été lancée
depuis la fin de l'été pour tous les
plus de 65 ans et les plus fragiles il
nous faut aujourd'hui l'accélérer
si vous avez été vaccinées il ya plus de
six mois
je vous appelle à vous protéger en
prenant rendez vous dès maintenant
auprès d'un centre de vaccination de
votre médecin ou de votre pharmacien il
est possible de faire ce rappel en même
temps que le vaccin contre la grippe à
partir du 15 décembre
il vous faudra justifier d'un rappel
pour prolonger la validité de votre pass
sanitaires
les personnes qui ont moins de 65 ans
voit aussi la protection conférée par le
vaccin diminuer au fil du temps
d'ailleurs au moment où je vous parle
plus de 80% des personnes en réanimation
ont plus de 50 ans c'est pourquoi une
campagne de rappel sera lancée à partir
du début du mois de décembre pour nos
compatriotes
âgés de 50 à 64 ans
nous avons saisi les autorités
scientifiques afin qu'elles puissent
nous indiquait dans les tout prochains
jours les modalités pratiques et les
échéances à suivre de la même manière
que nous avions d'ailleurs organisé vous
vous en souvenez sans doute durant le
premier semestre la campagne de
vaccination
le vaccin pour efficace soit il ne
suffit pas dans ce contexte de reprise
épidémique il nous faut en même temps
redoubler de vigilance tous les
assouplissements un moment envisagé
seront donc reportés pour conserver les
règles actuellement en vigueur
même si je sais combien c'est difficile
le port du masque à l'école sera donc
pour le moment maintenu
l'application des gestes barrières qui
protègent autant contre le coc vide 19
que contre les maladies contagieuses de
l'hiver doit aussi faire l'objet d'une
attention accrue
nous avions tous un peu relâcher nos
efforts et c'est bien normal il faut
donc les reprendre les contrôles pour
l'application du pass sanitaires dans
les établissements concernés et pour les
entrées dans les ports les aéroports les
gares seront renforcés et nous
continuerons comme nous avons toujours
fait à adapter nos décisions territoire
par territoire en fonction de
l'évolution de l'épidémie
c'est donc grâce à la vaccination au
pass sanitaires aux gestes barrières que
nous pourrons continuer de vivre ne pas
restreindre d'autres libertés et ne pas
refermer des activités enfin c'est parce
que la france a très tôt misé sur la
recherche sur les traitements et que
nous avancions commande est très en
amont que nous bénéficierons d'une
nouvelle arme pour lutter contre le
virus avec l'arrivée dès la fin de
l'année des premiers traitements
réellement efficace contre les formes
graves de cofidis
durant toute cette période notre nation
s'est toujours attaché à protéger chacun
d'entre nous sur le plan éducatif
économique et social nos enfants nous
avons été l'un des pays du monde qui a
le plus souffert ces écoles nos jeunes
nous avons accompagné les étudiants avec
le repas un euro et des aides
spécifiques pour les boursiers les plus
précaires grâce à une politique
d'hébergement sociale inédite et aux
aides exceptionnelles versées nous avons
évité à près d'un demi million de nos
compatriotes de basculer dans la
pauvreté nos artistes artisans
indépendants salariés entrepreneurs ont
été accompagnés avec le chômage partiel
les prêts garantis par l'état le fonds
de solidarité et de nombreuses aides
sectorielles
nous continuons et continuerons
d'adapter nos réponses en fonction des
besoins c'est pourquoi par exemple les
prêts garantis par l'état seront
prolongés jusqu'en juin 2022
nous avons aussi soutenu nos soignants
nous soignons qui ont tant donné durant
la crise et prouve aujourd'hui une
légitime fatigue ils ont été augmentés
de 200 à 400 euros net par mois en
moyenne
500 établissements hospitaliers vont
être restaurés des milliers de maisons
de retraite rénové grâce à un effort
sans précédent de 19 milliards
d'investissements partout sur le
territoire
ces mesures qui s'ajoutent à beaucoup
d'autres comme la fin du numerus clausus
pour les médecins ou l'augmentation du
nombre de postes d'infirmer font que
jamais depuis la création de la sécurité
sociale nous n'avions autant investi
dans la santé il le fallait il le
fallait après des décennies d'abandon de
sous investissement mais il reste je le
sais encore beaucoup à faire
cette stratégie du quoi qu'il en coûte
couplée aux 100 milliards du plan de
relance que nous avons décidé grâce à
notre initiative européenne non
seulement nous a permis de résister à la
crise mais de rebondir plus fort
aujourd'hui
notre croissance dépasse les 6% la
france est en tête des grandes économies
européennes
le chômage est au plus bas depuis près
de 15 ans et nous sommes l'un des seuls
pays du monde où le pouvoir d'achat a
continué à progresser en moyenne et où
la pauvreté n'a pas augmenté
nous avons réussi tout cela en
maîtrisant nos dépenses publiques
puisque notre déficit sera inférieur à
5% de notre produit intérieur brut dès
cette année tout cela c'est le fruit de
nos choix collectifs
et
c'est aujourd'hui encore que nous devons
prendre de nouvelles décisions pour
rester maîtres de nos vies comme citoyen
maîtres de notre destin comme nation
pour les années qui viennent oui parce
que nous avons devant nous une forme d'
accélération du monde des grandes
décisions
qui sont à prendre d'une part notre
situation économique reste toujours à
consolider dans un monde où les tensions
sur les approvisionnements et les coûts
des matières premières et de l'énergie
gnr pénurie et inflation je sais que
beaucoup d'entre vous le vivent d'autre
part parce que nous ne devons pas viser
seulement 7% de chômage mais bien le
plein emploi nous sommes en train
progressivement tous ensemble de réussir
de faire en sorte que chaque française
chaque français puisse par son travail
construire sa vie mener à bien ses
projets
notre économie crée des emplois comme
jamais au point que dans des secteurs
comme la restauration les bâtiments
travaux publics les services l'artisanat
ou l'industrie tous les entrepreneurs me
disent peiner à recruter aujourd'hui
au moment où trois millions de nos
compatriotes se trouvent encore au
chômage cette situation heurte le bon
sens pour la dépasser pour faire en
sorte que toutes les offres d'emploi
soient pourvus nous devons agir sur tous
les fronts depuis quatre ans le travail
paye mieux
avec l'augmentation de la prime
d'activité 200 euros au niveau du smic
avec la défiscalisation des heures
supplémentaires et des pourboires avec
les baisses d'impôts inédite par rapport
au début du quinquennat c'est au minimum
170 euros de pouvoir d'achat par mois en
plus pour les bas salaires
il faudra dans les années à venir
poursuivre ses choix et financer notre
modèle social en taxant - le travail
encore
nous avons aussi beaucoup formé avec 15
milliards d'euros mobilisés depuis 2010
est jamais autant de moyens n'avaient
été engagés pour la montée en compétence
des moins diplômés et des demandeurs
d'emploi pour notre jeunesse aussi nous
avons déployé un effort spécifique avec
la réforme de l'apprentissage de
l'alternance atteignant en ce moment
même des chiffres records et grâce au
plan un jeune une solution nous avons
aidé 3 millions de jeunes à trouver une
formation ou un emploi ou un
accompagnement ce qui fait qu'au moment
où je vous parle le taux de chômage pour
les jeunes est au plus bas depuis plus
de 15
pour les cinq cent mille jeunes sans
emploi et les moins qualifiés j'ai
annoncé dans la lignée de ce que je vous
avais dit le 12 juillet dernier le
lancement pour le 1er mars prochain du
contrat engagement jeunes un contrat et
non un revenu parce qu'au droit que nous
ouvrons à savoir 20 heures de suivi
intensif une allocation pouvant aller
jusqu'à 500 euros correspondent des
devoirs de voir d'assiduité devoir de
suivre les formations proposées et de
s'engager pleinement
plus largement pour que le travail
permette de vivre dignement et paie
toujours davantage que l'inactivité
nous conduisons en ce moment même une
indispensable réforme de l'assurance
chômage
depuis un mois les règles ont commencé à
changer pour rendre la reprise du
travail plus attractives dans tous les
cas et à partir du 1er décembre de cette
année une nouvelle étape va s'engager il
faudra avoir travaillé au moins six mois
dans les deux dernières années pour
pouvoir être indemnisé alors
qu'aujourd'hui les droits au chômage
sont ouverts au bout de quatre mois de
travail
enfin pôle emploi passera en revue les
centaines de milliers d'offres d'emploi
disponibles sans réponse dès les
prochaines semaines les demandeurs
d'emploi qui ne démontreront pas une
recherche active verront leurs
allocations suspendues
le 12 juillet dernier j'avais évoqué
devant vous la nécessaire réforme des
retraites la situation sanitaire que
nous vivons et qui est en train de se
dégrader partout en europe le souhait
unanime exprimé par les organisations
syndicales et professionnelles de
concentrer les efforts sur la reprise le
besoin de concorde dans ce moment que
vit notre nation font que les conditions
ne sont pas réunies pour relancer
aujourd'hui ce chantier
pour autant notre volonté de sauver
notre modèle par répartition et d'en
corriger les inégalités n'a pas changé
ce 1er novembre la retraite minimale
pour les agriculteurs qui est attendue
depuis si longtemps est entrée en
vigueur et dès 2022 il faudra pour
préserver les pensions de nos retraités
et la solidarité entre nos générations
prendre des décisions claires
elles feront légitimement l'objet de
débat démocratique indispensable
mais elles devront suivre à mes yeux des
principes simples
travailler plus longtemps en repoussant
l'âge légal aller vers un système plus
juste en supprimant les régimes spéciaux
en harmonisant les règles entre public
et privé et en faisant en sorte qu'au
terme d'une carrière complète aucune
pension ne puisse être inférieure à 1000
euros allez enfin vers plus de liberté
c'est à dire permettre de partir en
retraite progressivement d'accumuler des
droits plus rapidement pour celles et
ceux qui le souhaitent d'encourager le
travail au delà de l'âge légal aussi
pour celles et ceux qui en ont envie la
retraite ne doit être ni une contrainte
d'une angoisse mais un choix plus libre
plus simple plus lisible
aujourd'hui comme hier vous le voyez le
travail continue donc d'être notre
boussole le fil rouge de notre action
non seulement parce que pour chacun
d'entre nous c'est le travail qui nous
permet de créer des liens d'augmenter
notre pouvoir d'achat de progresser tout
simplement dans la vie en accédant à la
propriété en protégeant notre famille
nos proches en concrétisant nos projets
mais aussi parce que sur le plan
collectif
le travail de tous et ce qui nous permet
en tant que nation de faire nos choix et
de garantir notre indépendance
c'est par le travail et par plus de
travail que nous pourrons préserver
notre modèle social nos retraites la
prise en charge des malades
l'accompagnement des familles la
meilleure inclusion à l'école au travail
ou dans les structures adaptées pour les
personnes en situation de handicap c'est
par le travail aussi que nous
permettrons à nos aînés de vivre plus
longtemps chez eux ou d'être accompagné
une cinquième branche de la sécurité
sociale a été créée
elle sera pleinement mises en oeuvre
dans les mois qui viennent et d'ici au
1er janvier les professions du soin et
de l'aide à domicile auront vu leur
salaire revalorisé
nous sommes en train collectivement en
ce moment même malgré la pandémie de
construire pas à pas un véritable
service public de l'autonomie pour nos
aînés nous le finançons et le
financerons par davantage de travail
c'est par le travail de tout ce que nous
pourrons continuer de rendre notre état
plus solide nous avons depuis 2010 est
recruté dix mille policiers et gendarmes
nous avons substantiellement augmenter
le budget de la justice d'une manière
inédite les résultats sont là trente six
attentats déjoués la baisse d'un quart
du nombre de cambriolages et de vols de
véhicules des saisies et des
arrestations record en matière de trafic
de drogue mais très clairement nous
sommes lucides sur le travail qui reste
à faire la violence est de retour dans
toutes les sociétés occidentales et
exige d'aller plus loin nous devons
ainsi poursuivre et renforcer nos
actions pour lutter contre les violences
faites aux femmes pour mieux protéger
nos enfants et dans le prolongement des
travaux du bo vaud
une loi de programmation pour la
sécurité intérieure est en cours de
discussion elle sera présentée au
premier trimestre 2011 22 et donnera
plus de moyens et elle nagera les
contraintes bureaucratiques nos forces
de l'ordre nous avons aussi lancé les
états généraux de la justice qui
réunissant tous les acteurs déboucheront
au printemps sur des mesures fortes à la
fois pour que la justice soit rendue
plus vite et que les peines prononcées
soient réellement exécutées
c'est par le travail de tous enfin que
nous pourrons bâtir notre indépendance
énergétique
nous vivons chaque jour les conséquences
de la situation actuelle le plein plus
cher à la pompe la facture de gaz et
d'électricité qui augmente ce que nous
vivons ces dernières semaines nécessite
des réponses d'urgence c'est pour cela
d'ailleurs que le gouvernement à bloquer
les prix du gaz c'est aussi pour cela
que ceux d'entre vous qui gagnez moins
de 2000 euros nets par mois et recevoir
une indemnité inflation exceptionnelle
de 100 euros mais si nous voulons payer
notre énergie à des tarifs raisonnables
et ne pas dépendre de l'étranger il nous
faut tout à la fois continuer d'
économiser l'énergie et d'investir dans
la production d'énergies décarbonées sur
notre sol c'est pourquoi pour garantir
l'indépendance énergétique de la france
pour garantir l'approvisionnement
électrique de notre pays et atteindre
nos objectifs en particulier la
neutralité carbone en 2050 nous allons
pour la première fois depuis des
décennies
relancer la construction de réacteurs
nucléaires dans notre pays et continuer
de développer les énergies renouvelables
ces investissements nous permettront
d'être à la hauteur de nos engagements
au moment où nous allons clôturer la
coop 26 à glasgow c'est un message fort
de la france
vous le voyez bien et nous le présentons
tous dès à présent nous nous préparons à
affronter les défis de l'avenir
car nous vivons une révolution profonde
avec la pandémie nous avons éprouvé
notre vulnérabilité ce virus soudain à
bloquer le monde entier nous avons
redécouvert notre dépendance vis-à-vis
de l'étranger y compris pour des
produits de première nécessité des
masques le paracétamol ou d'autres nous
avons réappris avec le 25e l'innovation
pouvait tout changer et parfois en
quelques mois avec une rapidité inédite
en même temps les grands enjeux d'avant
la crise n'ont pas disparu la protection
de la planète le défi démographique le
vieillissement la montée des inégalités
nous avons donc d'une manière inédite
tant de décisions à prendre en même
temps tant d'investissements historique
à faire pour relever tous ces défis pour
maîtriser notre destin le marché seul ne
suffit pas il faut assumer une
intervention publique forte avec dans
quelques domaines clés des
investissements importants
les investissements de la nation des
investissements aussi de l'europe c'est
pour cela que j'ai lancé le plan france
2030 doté de 30 milliards d'euros sur
cinq ans pour investir dans dix secteurs
très porteurs d'avenir comme la
décarbonation de l'industrie le véhicule
électrique l'avion zéro carbone ou
encore la culture la santé le spatial ou
le maritime pour éduquer et former nos
jeunes dans ces métiers d'avenir pour
sécuriser en france la production de
composants et de technologies
essentielles comme les semi conducteurs
la robotique ou le cyber
notre objectif est clair que les
produits et les technologies qui feront
l'économie les emplois est en quelque
sorte les vides 2030 ne viennent pas
seulement des états unis ou d'asie mais
bien aussi de france et d'europe
certains pensent ce rêve inatteignable
je crois tout le contraire je crois que
cela relève même de l'ambition faisable
du volontarisme lucide si aujourd'hui
nous continuons de mener les et forme
des transformations et si nous
investissons
oui la france a les moyens de conforter
ses positions de grande puissance
éducative
industrielles agricoles d'innover de
créer produire en tenant nos objectifs
climatiques de biodiversité
si nous investissons si nous levons les
freins à l'action les complexité inutile
et les corporatismes
mais la france ne sera pas forte seuls
les enjeux sont tels dans le choc des
puissances continentales qui se déploie
sous nos yeux que seule une entente
européenne solidaire et volontaire peut
apporter à chacun de nos pays européens
un relais et une force de frappe il
suffit d'ouvrir les yeux pour mesurer
combien nos intérêts se rencontrer
s'accordent c'est dans ce contexte du
choc des puissances américaines
chinoises russes et de déstabilisation
de nombreuses zones du monde que notre
pays aura dans deux mois la charge de
présider l'union européenne
car les orientations de l'union ne sont
pas lointaine où évanescente elles sont
même la trame de nos vies et des années
qui viennent
sans l'union européenne nous n'aurions
pas si vite disposer du vaccin
nos partenaires ne sont pas des
étrangers sur ce continent qui nous a
été donnée par le destin ils sont
confrontés aux mêmes vagues au même
orage que ceux que nous rencontrons
c'est donc avec eux que nous tâcherons
dans les prochains mois
de mieux affronter les défis qui sont
les nôtres
ensemble de mieux protéger nos
frontières extérieures ensemble de
continuer à rebâtir avec l'afrique une
relation de paix de stabilité et de
croissance
ensemble de mieux réguler les géants du
numérique ensemble de bâtir une
stratégie crédible de réduction de nos
émissions de co2 compatible avec notre
souveraineté industrielle technologique
ce nouveau modèle d'investissement et de
croissance auquel je crois pour la
france et pour l'union européenne et
celui que je défendrai en votre nom dès
janvier prochain en prenant la
présidence de l'union
mes chers compatriotes
nous avons surmonté ensemble ces
derniers mois une conjonction inédite de
crise la pandémie ses conséquences le
terrorisme les désordres géopolitiques
et j'en passe j'ai tâché à la cavalcade
de retranscrire tout ce que nous sommes
en train de faire et ce qui convient de
conduire pour les mois à venir mais
durant tous ces mois nous sommes restés
soudés
fidèles à ce que nous sommes
profondément humain
alors je vois bien je sens bien
j'entends bien l'incertitude les doutes
parfois la fatigue quelquefois la colère
quand je viens à votre rencontre qui se
manifestent la période est difficile
pour beaucoup d'entre vous angoissante
mais regardez ce que nous avons réussi
durant ces derniers mois en agissant
ensemble
unis
nous avons réussi l'impensable
alors je vous le dis avec beaucoup de
conviction
n'ayant pas peur
croyons en nous croyons en la france en
une france qui restait elle même forte
de son histoire de sa culture de sa
langue de sa laïcité de ce qui l'unît
forte de son esprit de résistance à la
dilution dans un monde qui va à la
soumission aux dogmes aux obscurantismes
au retour du nationalisme
forte de sa volonté d'embrasser l'avenir
et de continuer d'assumer sa part
d'universel
croyons en nous nous le méritons
vive la république et vive la france